this place is really nice hank thank you
for taking me yeah it's uh
you know it's nice to treat yourself
every once in a while you know i'm very
sorry for the weight good evening madame
good evening
miss you good evening
before i tell you about our specials
maybe i could get you something from the
bar i think we'd both like some water to
start yeah we have bottled steel we have
sparkling
or um
perhaps i could just run the shower
for a moment and let you drink the water
the water that accumulates at the bottom
of the tub
is that some you could drink the shower
or whatever
yeah i think sparkling would be good
okay
i'll have a red wine please very good
house red and uh for you
sir um
you know i could um
i could see if the chef has something in
the cream family
maybe bring me some half and half or um
maybe see if we have the heavy cream
heavy cream that we cook with i don't
know
i don't know if you're celebrating
something tonight and want to splurge on
the heavy cream we're not celebrating
you could
pour that in a shallow bowl for you
shallow society
something that you could get at easily
without um
getting milk all over your whiskers
looks
silly red wine two red wines okay one
glass and one sausage in a glass okay
two glasses okay
um it's just a glass is not really good
for a
lapping the little laps with the tongue
a slow transfer of liquid
through the cast
tongue
glass okay
um a little bit about that menu it uh
pretty much broken down into small
plates and andre
it's not really broken into
dry
and wet
food
section that's that's fine uh some of
the foods are dry some are wet
if you like i can ask the chef if he
could perhaps mix some of the wet with
the dry
some of the wet food in the dry food
together right here that is here that is
good you know
i think i'm going to have the sirloin
actually medium rare the snap peas
the endive salad to start and uh if we
have room we'll have the table side
bananas foster for dessert please
okay
check out fancy feast over here